oddio no non mi dire no no ciao a tutti
bentornati solite stories
se avete richiesto in tantissimi
nuovamente le reazioni a trucchetti
strani assurdi noi siamo andati a
cercare i più strani che abbiamo trovato
ancora noi abbiamo visti così vedremo
assieme come sono questi trucchetti
assurdi nello specifico questi sono
trucchetti per momenti imbarazzanti e
quindi so già che rideremo bellissimi
per me perché con tutte le figure che
faccio è vero ma per tutto capita a
tutti di avere i momenti imbarazzanti
anzi se volete raccontate nei momenti
imbarazzanti i vostri nei commenti e noi
ci divertiremo a leggerle fine come
sempre potete scrivere commenti ora il
trucchetto che vi ha scioccato di più
qual è quello che vi è piaciuto di più
siete pronti prendere sul patatine pop
corn al tè caldo cioccolata calda
iniziamo subito allora iniziamo con il
primo trucchetto se hai un rossetto nei
denti che succede se c'è lo stesso se lo
avevo già visto da qualche beauty guru
successo di vedere della ceramica e col
rossetto col rossetto sui denti quindi
se si dimostrano che in pratica per
toglierlo dall'interno delle labbra
mette un dito su ciucci 11 che poi gli
togli il rispetto dall'interno sulle
labbra e pero questa funzione davvero
prevede un po il colore si fosse giocato
non sai dove le 13
lamenti lei dentro un ovetto kinder le
detto ragazzo che spettro è la
sorpresina dentro si troverebbe maggio
al cioccolato allora eyeliner sempre
pubblicato da fare questi sono più per
donna vediamo se si portano anche per
l'uomo
metti il correttore a prima fai la linea
poi con il correttore lago pena che
bravo e chi la sta cucendo una calza
bucata da delle case ha fatto dei guanti
cari limitare non male ma non è molto
imbarazzante questo quindi non so cosa
c'entra allora la maglietta secondo te
cosa si trasforma con un sacco a bravo
bravo come che riesce sempre a st
a indovinare il subito quelli che si
mettono mezzo mondo bello per mettere le
scarpe perché le scarpe sono
imbarazzanti si pensa cosa c'entra
contro chi ti imbarazzante
forse questo sì perché ha macchiato le
stelle la zona selleri della camicia era
un marrone ha fatto un vestitino
questo lo sbaglio va bene dai poco largo
se hai una maglietta rubate al tuo
ragazzo e ti stai troppo grande perché
più bello elastico e completa diversa il
vento con vestito ma anche questo
purtroppo non è imbarazzante
cos'è questo un'altra borsa forse una
busta un cappello matto che ha il
cappello
forse è bene un cappello enorme cappello
sembrava che abbia un po una copertina
in testa perché è importante
no scusate il marchio mettere pantaloni
sono quelli che così si aprono
all'improvviso io a roma sto nessuno
questa era una busta in plastica da un
padre mario che diano può capitare la
street art
ma viene pro capite nota bastate 48 sta
riparando con le con la pinzatrice ma
dove non deve essere così per the
invisibile pinto eccola pinzatrice
magari che la fanno dall'interno cassino
però i vari che altro sobbalzando non ti
danno fastidio e bustine fi che non era
lei ben sa bene potresti secondo me non
lo fate le vostre riva rete con il buco
50 mo di 69
129 lo so io un trucchetto non perché mi
sia successo che si buttano lì però un
trucchetto che funziona se il ciclo e
prima piazza dovete nascondervi prendete
una felpa o una giacca e legate vela
nella vita così non si vede più niente
almeno per un po siete salvi quindi
anche se gli succede questo distribuito
nei termini usate lo stesso trucchetto
testa sempre la stessa quali si sono
piegati vari saloni polverina che è
spiegata a sentire gli occhiali sporchi
questo serve a te perché in realtà
vitale porta gli occhiali tipo un panno
di emergenza fa quando ci serve punire
gli occhiali da e bello questo è data a
costare dai aspettavi le ascelle pezzate
sulla lapide affidato sulla cambiata ma
la caccia alle dita gialle hanno notato
no non mi dire no no ma come la sorbini
che sono per momenti imbarazzanti sono
trucchetti imbarazzanti perché la
signora andrebbe con un pub sotto la
scelta allora per fortuna e non l'ha
messo direttamente sotto la sella se non
sarebbe stato strano però non lo so
magari c'è magari funzioni ma mentre se
volete funziona perché comunque assorbe
il sudore però è un po imbarazzante
magari se qualcuno lo vede come fa a
vederlo dentro con la camicia un po
trasparente oppure tutta che si stacca
perché comunque
alzi la mano di robinho dal regista così
verde 008 dirigente si no ma insomma
questo ma come mai è un primario di
dietro le hanno questo non è sorgerà si
è dimenticata di tirare su gasser miele
sia trotta forza sede della trotta burro
di cacao e simo la ripara limitiamo a
tutte e il prepuzio nato addio ma è
sempre lei poverina 16 anche rotta la
cavezza che cosa sarà successo questa
volta si è rotta il bottone vediamo per
vita giallissimo no forse color
correction il colore delle video che
paura
in pratica la maratona cena
wow lo sta riducendo bello questo questo
geniale davvero cosa facciamo fare una
decorazione pertanto riferma wow s'è
vista allarga la maglia con lei lo
voleva
sì questa bello lo conoscevo il bouquet
ecco io in genere faccio così e infatti
poi rimane
all'infuori quando non potesse quello
cuccia così si rendesse disse di essere
una di quelle quei materiali che quando
gli stili si sciolgono e si attaccano
squaw bello prendiamo prendesse
l'imbarazzante qua schiaccio lui mi
avete consigliato alla stessa cosa per
lo sly wow
chissà se funziona non mai provato che
gli sta un po strettini acqua calda
forse si allarga così balsamo per
capelli visi tutto funzionale sa che non
lo conosco questo perché ha trascorsi a
dabo latina
questa è una tecnica che usavano il
fratello
poi dopo lo tiri ed è mai diventata due
taglie più grande
ecco come vi stavo dicendo prima questo
può succedere crollo per scatenare
questo trucchetto come penso che se
contro questo molto vecchio
allora se macchietto le mutande acqua
fredda a idrogeno di ferro a fossa
isolate però non tutti ce l'hanno eccome
9 improvvisamente acqua freder sale
[Musica]
cappelli james inverse acqua fredda e
stare e gli lasci giocare era notte
come trovi le macchie nelle coperte a
mettere un asciugamano fi
a meno che non ti muovi tantissimo
durante la notte ritrovi darci una mano
in testa c'era lì la mia zia schiuma da
barba
non lo sapevo questo lo stesso
maglioncino b che stava stretto
all'altra persona è la forza per che
scivola meglio adesso effettivamente
ovvero quando metti un maglioncino sulla
capita
cosa li è più facile far lasciandoli
pensa ma lasciate alla macchia no non ci
sono le righe di quello che c'è sotto
perché essendo liscio scorre bene
bello bello bello che su trucchetto che
sta dando per legare i pantaloni tipo io
dopo che ho mangiato tipo di tutto devi
allargarli un pezzo di gomma a quello
che posso per tenere fermo l'orecchino
se lo perdi ma se perdi la parte del
dietro si una scarpa la minaccia
noda il mondo nello no magari funziona
ma potrebbe anche rovinarle per ora
un'altra macchia vediamo come la toglie
una stima da barba sera il fondo si e
poi che mira a far la scusa fai prima a
lavarla direttamente senza scrivo da
balbo non esce al fondo di è difficile
da togliere senza farsi vuole lo smalto
per tenere sempre il bottone questo lo
trovate funziona ei non sapevo ma ecco
come gioca mi spiace sempre i piedi
dovrebbero per togliere la sporcizia una
limetta per unghie cosa faceva acqua
sarà scritto acqua e il fondo per
stiramento parola stiro qua
interessante cosa
[Musica]
altri momenti imbarazzanti gli stivali
che cadono lo scotch
sì io che seguo però non so se poi dà
fastidio alla pelle
[Musica]
[Applauso]
le monete
così per farle tenere basso poi seguiti
calano le monete dalla gonna a per
tirare fuori la cosa tipo un cappellino
col buco
vediamo come s bell'idea si può stare
però non ho mai visto un cappellino
invernale quindi il buco prelevati sono
so potrebbe essere utile io non ho mai
avuto i capelli così lunghi quindi
diciamo che d'inverno non te li neghi
quasi mai perché fa freddo in
particolare come i titoli con le scarpe
lima la scuola e poi ammesso che l'ha
scritto ok degli anni di stato via
perché su di sé nei vertici della volta
dopo veramente no va bene infatti questo
a casa l'amore tra l'anzhi e poi tutte
quante regioni alcol
oddio bellissimo quell'ora bellissimo di
carbonato di sodio e olio di cocco e
limone questo forse per sbiancare i
denti
adesso costruisciti con la nave è vero
il dissenso no lo mette nei peli delle
ascelle non settore massaretta a
concepire quindi con una crema che togli
i primi sapesse non ho messo lo studente
del genere pro magari si può provare la
maglia tour e sulla pancia a dovera tira
col lt fa benissimo il generale si vede
la collaborazione con l'ordine di cocco
forse con tanta applicazione svegli con
un brufolo sul naso succede sempre con
un mega brufolo brufolo grazie contro la
casa soprattutto prima di eventi
importanti
metti nel dentifricio a questo lo scuso
conoscevo già però bisogna stare attenti
perché a volte lascia un segno rosso
betsson sopra rispetto aspetta per due
minuti se lo scritto no e gli occhi
gonfi grandissima triolo arrivare
citrino aiuta molto invece di
grattugiato potete anche tagliare
tagliarlo a fette e appoggiarli studio
chi poi già che ci sei metti per la
banana non si sa mai e hai fatto la
colazione e poi il tutto sembra fi
cubetti di ghiaccio
oggi perchè il freddo aiuta la
circolazione del sangue qua
quindi dopo puzzerà e non solo dice che
trovano ma anche di banana vabbè dai
cattivo odore di cetriolo banana è
un'altra persona no dai non sera non si
colla ora ricoverato ghiacciando sta
facendo su come ci fosse e conserva la
per dopo allora il vero preparando da
mangiare di voi si sta bollendo il tutto
fosse l'aloe vera bollita poi ancora
buono coltivo è diventato di un colore
oppure si possono e si pone immagini il
profumo che è questo spray vediamo per
cosa lo usa mld ma infatti stavo
pensando proprio dei capelli
però dopo tv da farli bene stare molto
profumato come colla e non scappano
tutti e quindi li ha fatti lisci a per
farli crescere
allora se vuoi mettere il rossetto prima
di mangiare per non rovinarlo la calda
gelatina a per fare il rossetto colori
sì poi non si attacca quando mangi
oppure poi direttamente mettere il
rossetto dopo mangiato così eviti tutto
questo problema eccoveli
[Musica]
ma la mente a cena tolto perché permane
un velo di colore sopra ai fori troppo
aperti dispero diretto il bianco è il
vero ha aggiunto dello zucchero le fasi
rose piano è vera pelle perfetta per lo
stile dei fatti coda rinforzo mette il
foglietto sua e rimane attaccato di
nuovo polo non caristi non so se poi
rimane sempre attaccato però sembra ha
fatto molto bene come liberarsi del
doppio mento di mai politico e volte poi
trattiene il respiro per cinque secondi
con baciare la giraffa per cinque
secondi verificare questa devi fare così
che non asciugamano 30 volte e basta mi
sento queste cose qui il doppio mento
sta ancora lì però potrebbe essere
chissà quante cose bisogna farlo magari
sono esercizi per il doppio mento da
fare tutti riforme 8 volta che facendo
di più però basa la giraffa
ma questo è quello che ho provato ha
lasciato senza parole il mio segreto per
la casta vale ascelle c'era un impegno
in orbita rivela che il soggetto era
quello che facevo con l'intruglio lì che
poi se lo scavo però ebay comunque
scrivete voi nei commenti lasciati in
time stamp del trucchetto che vi ha
fatto più ridere un momento che vi ha
fatto più ridere e fateci sapere altre
reazioni che volete che facciamo altri
video scrivete seppure quali video e noi
vi lasciamo ora qua quattro carceri
lines pubblicare per vedere i nostri
altri video divertenti trucchetti
challenge cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione
ciao